basically there is a lot to love about
jojo that's the last dick suck i will do
of jojo
yes the fandom is probably one of the
worst if not the worst right now
publicly like it's pretty [ __ ] awful
yeah it's pretty bad
i wish you guys would chill the [ __ ] out
yeah exactly because like
because i feel like the only time i've
had a knee-jerk reaction about someone
saying nothing
about jojo i had that i had to exactly
i had this like i became everything i
hated
i mean i've already talked about this
but it's uh
critical it's when critical did what did
you do a video on again
he was talking about uh it was donkey's
video uh about oh
yeah yeah about how final fantasy fans
are the worst and like they're like
so aggressive about their opinion yeah
so it's a critical video that's called
donkey has gone too far i think that's i
think
something like something like that yeah
and so charlie talks about
how you know these rabid final fantasy
fans
have taken donkey's opinion way too
seriously yeah
right yeah and then he goes in this he
he uses this analogy
and of course of course he uses jojo
and i was when he brought up jojo i was
ready to be like
you're right king totally you are
totally right i totally get dropped this
yeah part one sucks part three sucks we
get it yeah yeah
and then he goes on to say that i think
he prefers
part one and two to part three and four
and i just had this
i just had this cho tamate i've never
hit the space bar with such aggression
what what
because i've i've heard most opinions
about jojo i've heard shitty too no
that was the shittiest charlie what was
that what is that charlie
part four is amazing i just want you no
no i just
want to understand no no i'm on the
podcast charlie excuse me
look i don't want to be that jojo fan
right now
but i'm going to fully morph into that
jojo because like
i've heard you know if you don't like
jojo that's fine i've heard that take so
many times when i'm just like
yeah jojo's not for you that's good
that's fine you know but i've never
heard the take where
someone someone prefers parts one and
two over parts
three and four maybe like maybe part two
of a part three but part one
yeah part one over pi over three and
four four
four is amazing i don't know i don't
like the
personified powers i'd rather see the
powers i can't [ __ ] see
charlie charlie this this you know i
just want i just want to understand
i want to understand i need to know this
this isn't right here charlie for you
to explain yourself it's not hate i just
want to know
i want to know because me and connor
both like space bar this
go to the comment section and nobody was
talking about it
normally nobody was really about i was
so furious it's like why is nobody
talking about that
this is this is the biggest issue in
2020.
why isn't it only because they're all
off on like a slash jojo being like did
you see this
did you see this [ __ ] i i i i've
i've nev i've never had a reaction like
that in my life i've normally been like
yeah king whatever you want man
and i was like no no that is wrong what
is that's just wrong because it's
literally the first time i've heard this
opinion
never heard that i i thought i was
prepared for anything so yeah charlie
come on and defend yourself
[Laughter]
we need to we need to talk